i just want to start with thank you i
laughed my ass off last night and i just
want to say thank you for everything
that you do
awesome oh yeah thank you thank you you
know i think that when a movie sucks the
studio doesn't let everybody watch it
because they don't want people to say
it's bad yeah yeah yeah this one they've
let everybody watch
because it's so good huh
you know what i'm going to tell you the
secret um if people come in and have a
smile on their face and are like saying
[ __ ] like i'm saying that means they
actually really liked it if people are
just jumping in and like you know what i
mean you can tell when someone actually
likes what they're talking about yeah
yeah
doing these press junkets is generally
kind of a nightmare but this one's not
so bad because we're so thrilled with
this movie
yeah as well you should be um i am a big
fan of jackass i know people that are
going to watch this are big fans um what
do you actually think would surprise
people to learn about the making of a
jackass movie that we went from
handheld vhs cameras to a full-blown
uh
movie production to now do jackass well
yeah i think that thank you
i think the extent to which the
production
went from small to massive over the
whole time is pretty stark um is there
i feel like jeff is willing to put you
guys through the ringer and just
literally do anything is there a safe
word that like you can utter that says
to jeff please leave me the [ __ ] alone
well
preston had this safe word before and it
just changed recently a friend called
him and said it's changed
preston's old safe word was oklahoma but
a friend of his called him and said i
think i have yours beat and preston goes
bring it and the guy goes the new safe
word is meatloaf
because there's things i will do or
there's something i can do anything for
[Applause]
[Laughter]
for all three of you what is literally
the most scared you've been when
standing on set like
freaking out like this i need to leave
for me
the bowls are horrifying yeah like
watching knoxville get in front of bulls
is the hardest especially watching it
yeah just wondering if
it's gonna be too bad because you know
it's going to be bad because it's a big
bowl you never know what's going to
happen you're going to be impaled by one
of your horns any anything can happen
yeah and i think
more than even being like i wouldn't
want to be in it but
it's scary to watch yeah so yeah yeah
bulls are scared we're gonna have to do
that
uh one of the things spike jones is
obviously involved in this but i feel
like he doesn't really get like pushed
through the ringer like everyone else is
he sort of like uh not allowed to be
[ __ ] with or is it just not on camera
we're on the other side of the camera
we've been told not to take it as far
with him as we do with everybody else
right i i kind of figured you know
yeah you know
um i i already got a wrap just real fast
is have you ever traded a stunt on set
you're like i cannot do this and someone
else swaps in i have one from back in
the day
uh and it's a poster of knoxville
getting bit in the nipple with a little
baby alligator
they came to me first they had the
alligator in hand and they said wait a
minute put it let it bite your nipple
and i was like hell no and then they
went right to knox he did it next thing
you know it's a poster
and i was like damn
i gotta pass that up again yeah i'm
never gonna pass that one up again i've
not tried a stunt but i've i've made an
agreement for us to do a stunt if it
would get get me out of trouble for
something bad i did and for something
bad i was going to do in the future
um
which was drinking horse semen of course
stephen yeah i don't know that i've
traded any bits
now stevo will do all his bits
and he's jealous of other people doing
other bits so there's no way i can ever
think of steve oh ever trading or giving
up a bit the carpet
that's the only one that is the only one
yeah i backed out of the carpet and and
gave it to ryan dunn
on that note i got to stop but i really
i really mean this thank you guys for
the years of entertainment i really
sincerely say it thank you have a
fantastic day
we're stoked that you loved it
you